[Music]
my deepest Pharaoh's about the agama
when the campster give up she was
through all that just to be shot in the
living room by Barbara it sounded like
she knew him it sounded personal yeah he
supposed every mother's person you know
what the best adventures be rich
you could have mother wish to protect
you from what Nazis Jonathan god damn
Nazis
this is living in that neighbors they
blinded themselves to us you can get
away with anything in America so your
grandmother and I clean it down on this
you put together a group of Nazi house
where a lock picker spy soldier master
of disguise shudder whose two weapons
experts you would bring God's justice
what do you say I want
agent Morris I think there's Nazis
living in America and someone out
there's taken him out there is a right
way and a wrong way to get justice can
you do this to become the evil you are
fighting now broadcasting or something
it's a coded message we find them before
they find out
trying to save your work there's a lot
more where this came from
[Music]
I need to learn how to fight I know a
few people you know
[Music]